meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
episode der seite liegen wer sein
maulheld dem geht es gut nachdem das
jetzt auch geklärt weil die behörde habe
ich heute meine gäste begrüßen und zwar
über 3 was hast du erwartet aber damit
steht das geht nicht immer auch und mein
team partner für die heutige runde ja
ein beispiel heute youtuber tabu leute
jedes team hat vier youtuber vorbereitet
2 die partie stand gestellt werden
müssen heisst ohne reden einfach nur mit
gesten und nochmal zwei die nach dem
ganzen klassischen tabu christi beraten
werden heißt man muss das wort oben
beschrieben hat 45 verschiedene weiter
die verboten sind weil der beschreibung
netz blockieren vorbereitet war erst die
vorbereiteten zettel mit den dann
braucht er jetzt sagen ja gern
beschreibt zu mir und versuchst warten
und dann noch 18 3 sekunden heute
trainiert
[Musik]
ja ich mache also die punkte kann wird
der celik bruder max mit finger zeigen
und hier bewusst schillig
reingeschrieben drittel maximal 3 2 1
sprecht mir fährt einen dicken mercedes
das könnte von einer anderen gruppe
sein alltag nicht mal mit zum bauen ohne
bedeutung und leute habt ihr bock auf
der zunge und ohne edition nächste
youtube
da habe ich auch schon ein alter es war
sie beginnt in der balance der töpfer-
und er ist auch das machen die meisten
menschen ist die frage ist wie willst du
vegane in ihrem katholisch darstellen
man hat sich gezogen wie kann der
ernährung zu wählen achso [ __ ] du dass
du musst
ich freue mich dass ja ich habe dich da
eine idee
felix barzelt auf der led leuchte okay
was ist nun led leuchten weiß ich nichts
nwd kopf nein in die qualität des essens
über verspielt ist ein gamer den 2
und er blickt das ist so gemein aber die
nächste party ob dies das für mich wie
es richter jetzt muss jahren wieder bis
zu erklären konnte
er hat schon jetzt das muss jetzt mehr
durch jan muslimen machen
12.30 uhr tsg thannhausen
ok katja joggi ja ja heute was sie gerne
institut kann man gemacht könnt ihr
jetzt denkt man an der stelle an der der
staat darüber aufgabe marc marquez du
bist da mit kathrin 3 2 1 und das geht
nicht
nein nie wieder so geht das nicht
das ist ungefähr dem schnellsten
erwarten die kuba in ganz deutschland 3
meine anders kannst von 4 auf 10 321
okay wir suchen eine besuchen eine
weibliche youtuber sind ja auch in einer
fernsehshow reservierter deiner musik
casting während sie schon von der ist es
ja genau wie heißt du wärst hier ist
sieht ja wohl ist hat er gesagt ist in
dieser stelle panda was wie gesagt alles
tut um dinge die kannst ist klar dafür
natürlich nicht wer ich bin so maßlos
über will ich den man sie dafür max los
also ohne den planeten mars
wir suchen einen männlichen youtube
die sachen von anderen news treffen
nicht sondern deutsche youtube bei dem
er seine sachen liegt habe ziemlich
bekannte junge mir das war richtig krass
kann man ja erstmal sechs sekunden
in diesem sinne was diesen kennt viele
leute aus dem urlaub vielleicht schon
soweit last gerne drei laster und hoffen
jetzt bitte nicht von hin und werd ich
bin da nicht die hauswand da hinten ist
dunkler ist gut